don't do that hey
everybody are you ready for
a good good good good good time
[Music]
god i'm old man i'm getting old i have
gray pube i found my first grape pube
and uh wait that's untrue
unequivocally no i thought i've been
finding gray pubes the ones i could see
where you are blind yeah the ones i can
see i had some underlings
under the shaft yeah yeah a couple like
you know larry and gary
and they were just kind of like there
for a couple years and this is what they
look like like this
but you've always had i'm just letting
you know right now i'm not gonna show my
people
how is that [ __ ] cancelling or
anything it's weird
if pubes are close enough but we're
family vic jason
i apologize about that all right so
anyway um
i discovered some pubes i [ __ ] was in
a panic so i got a [ __ ] i got to shave
i'm getting so
i'm sorry i want is this bothering you
i'm just letting you know you've had
salt and pepper since the day i met you
so i don't know what you're saying oh
that long ago i can see why you've had
the ones that i can see okay all right
it's like in a house
termites i can't see them so it's not a
problem
[Laughter]
until they are that's a good point is
that a good point or not that's a very
good point thank you so much all right
so basically i had a couple of termites
in the shed
right that i couldn't see but then one
popped out and said what's that
um right so then i went on a frantic you
know
pube [ __ ] shifted i actually shaved my
pubes so that andrew santino could eat
them
oh and i can i i ate some of his pubes
andrew santino's pubes we're not going
through a global pandemic at all are we
how did you know about that what i
didn't know about the poo
delivery i didn't know i heard about
that too
yeah yeah so we gave a pube delivery you
did a pubility yeah yeah yeah
i don't think you can get covered
through eating someone's pubes what did
it taste like
i'll tell you why are you guys stealing
ideas from jeremiah watkins and steve
lee
we might have stole that but um i got a
i got a red pube stuck between the teeth
oh right
and i found out maybe five hours later
when i was at home
and i looked like this and there was a
little red pubes sticking out of my red
to
to on my tooth right my bread too does
he have red pubes
it's so gross babe really but like
darker no it's like you went to go to
toys r us
and got a chucky doll and shaved its
head that's how orange it looks like
like almost like um manufactured
red hair for dolls it's kind of cool
it's gross anyway we have a guest and i
don't want to
go on keep going about that um she was
three hours late
um oh i'm kidding
i'm [ __ ] kidding um you know i'll
tell you something about her
um i knew i probably know her about a
decade maybe
and um you know i'll be honest with you
i'm an old guy
and you know you know i started showbiz
i like saying showbiz back in my um
20s but that was in the 90s and there
wasn't anybody
that looked like me doing it it was very
kind of
you couldn't really i bonded with a lot
of hispanics
back then you know i mean like the
gabriel iglesias and the
mencias and those types of jeff garcia
and those kinds
and um i love the hit my hispanic hola
que tal bien bien
la escuela la hambro guessa por favor
that's all i know but um then there was
like a group group of
young asians on the internet
and at first you know you know being uh
older you kind of look and you kind of
go
i'm gonna defeat these kids that's the
first feeling